this is jus I'm 34 why would I lie I'm
34 years old yeah you should applaud
that I've wanted to be in my 30s my
entire life that's true that is true I
would never lie to you even when I was
12 I was like that looks pretty sweet I
got to get out of the sandbox and into a
cardigan that's gonna be great box of
wine scratchy pants yeah and little Pete
was right being 34 is the best it's the
best I don't understand people that want
to extend their twenty-something
behavior into their 30s just be 30 don't
walk around with your vintage fake atari
t-shirt ironically reading a copy of
good night moon you got it Urban
Outfitters you're 30 be 30 it's the best
come join me in 30 it's great you get to
do all sorts of new things adult
grown-up that sounds like sex you can
have sex at any well there cert hmm
some ages are better than others for sex
I'll leave that ok just steer away from
this topic what I'm saying is you can do
things that are fun to do as a grown
person like waking up earlier than you
need to that is right that is a sign I'm
34 I wake up before I need to when I was
in my 20s I would set my alarm 15
minutes before I had to be at work not
before I had to leave for work before I
had to be at work 15 minutes to go to
the bathroom shower and commute to my
job as a waiter and I'd hit the snooze
button like huh I'll just at
Bennigan's
but now I'm in my 30s I get up early I
elect to get up early and I have a
morning
that's grown-up having a morning
you know I get up an hour before I even
have to leave for work open it with one
of these stretches of you like a cartoon
dad that even felt good just doing it in
the bed why don't we do that more water
my lawn in my open bathrobe sipping
coffee out of my lucky mug just a little
humming a song a song that doesn't even
exist just the madness in my mind oh you
know how grown people do that if you
ever waiting in line behind someone in
their 30s 40s or 50s it like a Barnes &
Noble listen to the tune it's not a song
it's just something like I've heard all
the songs here's something from me
that's what I do because I'm owning 34
here's one of the main differences
between being in your 20s and being in
your 30s from me like the other day I
went to the Hollywood ball I went to a
rock and roll concert yeah that's what
we people in our 30s call rock and roll
concerts it's fun watching people in
their 20s react to hearing that because
it really really gets their goat yeah we
also say gets their goat that's a
but it was a great crowd this is my
point it was a great crowd of the show
it's a great audience a lot of
electricity a lot of energy in the air
and a great show and as soon as the band
came out to do their like first encore
there's how I know I'm 34 I turned to my
friend and when we should get the
out of here so we can beat traffic and
he was like hell yes cuz he was in his
30s too but when you're 20 you feel like
you have to stay we got to stay for the
big encore why you know what's better
than hearing the Encore guessing what
its gonna be and blasting that song in
your car as you sail home through clear
streets just don't worry yeah you can
listen to free fallin all the way home
and then you know where you'll be hey
guys you know where you'll be then home
the best place 34 year old Pete loves
home home unnecessary swear Oh bed
snacks the home toilet advantage the
evening shower whoa is there anything
better than an elective evening shower
you don't even need it you just want to
stand in the glory of hot water
like God loves you with warm rain like a
goddamn Prince just like Eddie
be glad you're 34